make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
before we get into this video for the
twitch stream the comics explained
twitch stream where we basically just
stream the videos 24 7. we've got a
schedule now and so if you go to
twitch.tv
comics explained you'll see a schedule
down there but you can also type
exclamation mark schedule and that will
pull up what the schedule is right so
it'll tell you what that week's video is
we're also going to do a live q and a
session
every friday at 6 30 p.m and then a
watch party at 7 30 p.m right like
watching comic book movies and different
things like that together you do need
amazon prime to be able to do it but
yeah so it's it's cool right so
twitch.tv
comments explain it's a cool concept i
like it i think it's pretty awesome i
love i love talking to you guys right
like i was in there for like seven hours
yesterday and we made up like a comic
book video game it's basically skyrim
meets marvel comics it's amazing
but yeah so um this three joker story
is ridiculously good right like it's
it's crazy how good it is and here's the
thing a little bit of history here for
those of you guys who are kind of coming
into this and you're like okay i don't
remember everything that's going on
so this really comes out of the events
of what was
basically dark side war right like kind
of like this revelation when batman was
on the mobius chair which was the chair
that granted him absolute knowledge and
he asked the question who's the joker
and we were told there's three of them
and what we were basically given here
was
what was essentially the original joker
right so the old like bob kane
bill finger joker then we have the
killing joke joker and then we have the
silverado choker right so we've got like
three of them running around three
jokers from three different eras and at
this point we're just now learning what
all this is about right like three or
four years after it was all kind of
teased but what this does is it
basically picks up with batman
right inside the bad cave basically
receiving treatment for you know having
been out for
you know fighting crime that night
really kind of the run-of-the-mill stuff
the cool thing about this right this
this art is done by jason feybach he's
probably one of the greatest artists in
the entirety of comic book artistry and
of course
written by jeff johns but you have this
thing where like like batman's basically
being tended to by alfred and we get
these
these scars of batman right like the
scar on his back where bane broke his
back a scar where he was basically
burned by the riddler where he was
scratched by catwoman where he was bit
by killer croc he was
stabbed by the scarecrow he was shot by
joker just like all these different
scars but the cool thing about this is
we're given like these different
injuries
at the hands of various jokers over the
years right the three different jokers
right where he was sprayed with like
with the the acid lapel where he was cut
with a playing card like it's
kind of cool right because we get this
little bit of a flashback to like the
early days of batman
the very early days of bruce right where
you have bruce and his family walking
out of the mask of zorro movie bruce is
excited about it he's like yeah man it's
like the coolest thing ever then they
end up down at dark alley because his
dad wanted to take a shortcut and his
parents were shot by joe chill this is a
little bit of an origin for bruce now
this is kind of
if i had to be honest it's kind of jeff
jones just being like let's get to the
humanity of all of this
but like let's break bruce down to his
most base form right who is bruce
he's a sad little kid crying because his
mommy and his daddy got shot right
that's one of the best lines from like
the bat what was it batman begins but
like where bruce wayne like after his
parents are killed he goes to like tom
wilkinson who's in like that bar
that really city bar you know and he's
like he's like there's a congressman
there's a judge and so on and so forth
and he's like he's like you think
because your mommy and your daddy got
shot that you understand what this life
is like like you've never tasted
desperate
right like you're the you're you're
bruce wayne you're the prince of gotham
you have to drive a thousand miles to
find someone who doesn't know your name
like i love that line right because it
perfectly encapsulates bruce wayne right
he's just a little rich kid whose mommy
and daddy got shot and now he
understands the criminal underworld like
it's it's cool because in the early days
that was not the case now in the midst
of all this
we're they're suddenly met by the
arrival of a broadcast it says that like
the moxen crime family were all
executed at a restaurant essentially and
the execution was done at the hands of
the joker the next thing that really
goes on here
is that we switch over to batgirl and
while batgirl is exercising we end up
getting this this
news footage of a comedian who was
executed by the joker and it's kind of
cool because for
for her she basically hits at this idea
of of her having been shot by the joker
during killing joke which the reason why
this joker is kind of considered
separate from the other ones is because
originally killing joke was not part of
the dc continuity right it was a story
that was just out there by itself
somewhere but it was
wildly popular when it came out right
when it was released and even now
it's still considered to be the
definitive origin of the joker but the
idea is that barbara gordon kind of
relives a time when she was shot by
by the joker just to basically torture
her and to show her tortured images to
jim gordon to prove that he could make
jim gordon go insane but the next thing
it does is it switches over to something
that i totally did not expect
it switches to the red hood right it
switches over to jason todd and you have
jason todd here who's basically facing
off against some henchmen right just
beating the crap out of these guys
all the while reliving these memories
when the joker beat him to death
right when the joker basically killed
him now again as most of you guys
probably know this was in response to
the fact that dc fans didn't like
jason todd right that when dick grayson
was brought onto the scene in in the old
detective comic stories and he was the
first robin and the sidekick of batman
for
something like 30 years or something
like that when dc finally rolled him
over and made him nightwing when he was
basically aged up they wanted to keep
the element of robin right so they
brought in jason todd the problem was
that jason todd's origin story was like
identical to dick grayson's and fans
didn't like it because they thought that
it was dc just kind of throwing away the
story of dick for the purpose of just
like
creating another version of his
character and so what this did is it led
to dc
killing jason todd but the red hood is
here because he's basically
interrogating the guys or the joker
right he's interrogating his henchmen
and is like
tell me what it like tell me where the
joker is but the next thing we do is we
pick up with this major
this kind of death of these individuals
at the ace chemical factory
and you've got like jim gordon and
you've got harvey bullock and you've got
these guys responding and kind of
looking over this whole scene batman of
course
ends up showing up here and the reason
why is because what what's what's
happened
is that over the course of a single
night all three jokers
struck right the moxen crime family the
ace chemical factory being robbed and
the comedian being killed this
all happened in one night and that's
where like harvey bullock and jim gordon
and then were like okay this doesn't
make any sense right there's no way the
joker could have could have taken out
could have done all three of these
things he'd have to be in three places
at once
the only way it's true is if there's
three of the jokers running around and
notice this the immediate answer here is
okay well if there is more than one
joker then you have one joker and two
imposters that's the knee-jerk throwaway
reaction but you basically end up having
batman essentially talking to somebody
and of course the cops think he's more
or less lost his mind
only for us to find out he's talking to
batgirl and that this ace chemical this
this that basically is the one that
joker originally fell into back in like
batman number one or really kind of not
really batman number one definitively
but the original joker fell
into this vat of edits chemicals and
became the joker right so it has
significance it has meaning only for us
to find out that one of these guys
is basically still alive right one of
these individuals who was kind of
dousing the chemicals and so on is still
alive the other part of this
is that we end up finding out that when
it came to these three particular crimes
the joker wanted people to know he did
them it's why like when he was walking
through this ace chemical factory he
looked at every single security camera
that was working it's why he
livestreamed one of the murders in every
single one of these cases
he wanted people to know he was there so
people would kind of look and and it
would
literally draw them you know drive them
crazy and say like what in the world is
going on here now for these three bodies
that were here these are just
you know just a distraction it's
designed to keep the cops focusing on
them as opposed to focusing on the tire
tracks
of course batman picks up on that but
with this one guy being alive he's
thrown into an ambulance
and basically begun you know they they
start the purpose of getting him to the
to the hospital only for us to find out
that inside the ambulance is jason todd
right is the red hood who immediately
grabs this guy and like starts getting
to work on him and he's like tell me
everything you know now here's the cool
thing this is what i love so much about
this
right i firmly believe that in dc comics
right now
no one can write batman characters the
way that
jeff johns can scott snyder is really
good at like world building right he's
good at like building a mythos i think
jeff jones is you know a little better
than that proven by by the nature of
like the green lantern mythos but scott
snyder's good at writing a particular
kind of story
the creepy batman but in terms of
writing batman as we imagine him
right like this dark brooding character
when you think of like jason todd you
know as like this this hardcore
vigilante
jeff johns knocks it out of the park
here right like he he he smashes it out
of the park because when batman breaks
into the ambulance right and confronts
the red hood the red hood and batman get
into like a little bit of a scuffle
right this leads to barbara gordon
basically using her
using a kind of drill of swords attached
to the wheel of her
motorcycle and then taking out the tires
but then we switch over to this truck
right we switch over to the ace chemical
truck which is taken and then driven
into like this kind of wooded area
and then you end up having of course
like the joker getting out of it the
joker walking into a house or at least
walking up to a house he knocks on the
door
and he's met by the killing joke joker
right so you got two jokers here and so
you kind of have them you know going
going back and forth a little bit just
kind of being goofy telling jokes but
it's designed to showcase the nature of
their personalities
it's designed to show that like this
silver age joker was more cartoonish
right this guy was a little more silly
now the reality is that this version of
the joker was
was in a lot of ways the one that like
steve ingelhart's joker was based on
it's the one that batman the animated
series joker was based on he was a
little more sadistic than those versions
but like he
it's it's kind of that version of the
joker in a lot of ways and then killing
joke joker
is the one who's like dark there's
there's just there's something about him
it's just like
he's really really dark right like he's
hiding a monster inside right worse than
anything we've seen right it just looks
very sinister but of course they they
you know get inside the house and you
know basically killing joke joker tells
uh
you know killing joke joker tells a
silver age joker
wait until you see what the boss has
cooked up and that's what you end up
getting you kind of end up getting you
know these these two jokers talking to
the original joker this is the old
school
batman number one joker now look how old
he looks
that's one of the first things that hit
me this guy looks old he's been playing
the part for a while but basically he
tells him like we're going to split into
groups right like we're going to split
up and we're all going to go achieve a
goal right while we're going to do
something and so basically you end up
having batman and you have
jason todd and you have barbara gordon
who team up because each of them going
after a joker alone is basically suicide
because of how dangerous the joker is
the only real way for them to seemingly
pull this off
is to team up on one joker after another
right to you know all three of them hit
one joker all three of them hit another
and the three of them hit the last one
and that flies in the face of
conventional wisdom because historically
speaking they would have gone
gone through individually and then like
face off against the different different
characters right so like something seems
a little amiss like something seems
you know a little a little strange but
it's the smartest move to make
but getting into the gotham city
aquarium we end up finding out that like
this is where the silver age joker's
been
because what we end up getting here are
basically the joker fish right the
laughing fish the fish that have been
infected with the joker toxin not only
that and this is probably the single
creepiest thing that i think i've ever
seen in my life a laughing shark
this is horrifying and even jason todd's
like dude that's new
[Laughter]
that's new like that's a little bonkers
but of course then you end up having
like some silver age henchmen who
basically show up here you end up having
gaggy who was just kind of like
he was he was almost like joker's own
little robin to a degree it was kind of
weird
and a little twisted but they basically
end up you know kind of going in and you
know going after uh batman because
they've basically been tasked to do so
by the silver age joker now notice as
they get into this fight there's
gunshots being pulled
there's gunshots going and those
gunshots going are shooting into the
end of the tank they're literally
starting to crack the glass right and
what this does is it leads to jason todd
shooting the glass out of the tank the
shark comes flying out right it's just
like this
i mean shark's so roar but like you know
like it comes flying out and then like
eats gaggy
right and then the joker comes out of
nowhere and basically launches his
attack on like batman and the bad family
now the fact that the joker comes
running up on them with a with a bowl
like with a with a fishbowl full of the
laughing fish
this is silver aged joker this is the
kind of stuff he did right this is the
kind of comedic goofy nonsensical stuff
that the joker did back in the day like
that's just
the way he was during the silver age
he's immediately incapacitated by batman
and the bad family right now this right
here is our biggest clue there's
something bigger is going on
because of what sense would it make to
have the story how to have like a three
issue story about the three jokers and
like
they're all taken out in the first story
what kind of sense would that make why
that be a little weird
you have like commissioner gordon and
you have harvey bullock who chime in and
say like we got the other one and it
looks like the one that they took out
was the
uh was the killing joke joker although
we don't really see specifically
which one it is but it's like okay so
like he literally tells uh he tells
jason todd right he tells red hood and
he tells bad girl keep this guy roped up
you guys know how the joker is he's
always got something up his sleeve
like keep this guy away like like make
sure he's tied up make sure he doesn't
have a means of escape or anything like
that and it's one of these things where
you end up having red hood who like
pulls out one of the joker's playing
cards and the joker tries to spray him
with like his his acid lapel but then he
starts taunting jason
and this is the smartest thing this is
this is what made silver age joker so
cool and so sadistic if you go and you
read like the old like the old silver
age comics of the joker right if you go
and you read this this version of the
joker that we saw that basically existed
between like the onset of the silver age
and
like the beginning of like the crisis
events right like like infinite crisis
final crisis right if you look at this
version of the joker
this is if you look past the the
silliness if you look past the nonsense
of it he's
wildly dangerous and he's incredibly
smart like if you if you look if you
look past all that stuff the way he's
written
he's amazing and he was really good at
getting in your head he was really good
at like getting getting in heroes heads
and screwing with him and that's what he
does with jason
right he's like it's kind of interesting
when jason goes to pull a gun and
barbara's like you know like don't do
this batman wouldn't do this the
response to the joker is i mean you're
right like batman wouldn't do this but
batman's not here
is he look at the facts let's look at
what's really going on like
i killed this guy i beat you with a
crowbar i blew you up and the mistake
you made jason was believing that you
mattered in all of it that's the mistake
you made do you believe that i did that
because i was targeting you
i was never targeting you jason todd
your collateral damage you were bait i
was targeting you
to target him i was hitting at you to
get to batman and then he starts kind of
making fun of him right he starts poking
at him and basically saying like you're
basically my robin now that's really are
you that's really what you are i mean
look at yourself you exist
in gotham you take people's lives you
make batman's life an absolute living
hell like you're my you're my robin
you're my henchman you you became
everything that i hoped you would you're
my henchman now you're me it's like dude
like i never looked at it that way
i never looked at it that way and it's
the craziest thing because he tells him
he's like do you remember what you said
when i was beating you with that crowbar
when i was killing you remember what you
said you said please please
why are you stop doing this i'll tell
you anything you want if you stop
and it's kind of nuts because like when
we're getting that little bit of history
there
jason todd starts to cry right because
it's it's super personal
this is jason todd's version of like his
mom and dad being shot right the death
of jason todd at the hands of the joker
is far more potent because i mean if you
go and you look at like the or the
original origin original origin right
like when he first appeared in dc comics
his origin was the same
as dick grayson but that origin doesn't
really count anymore and so now it's
basically like jason todd was an orphan
you know somewhere along the line so
this is like a
super personal thing right he's being
made to relive the single biggest trauma
in his life
and i love love love the way this is
being handled right i absolutely love
the way that jeff charles is doing this
it makes red hood so personal if i'm
being honest with you guys i feel like
this personal touch of red hood has been
missing from dc
comics for a long time it's one of the
reasons why i stopped reading the red
hood comics
right because i feel like the like the
the actual core who really is jason todd
and let's focus on that has been gone
for a while the stories have been cool
he's been shooting a lot of stuff up but
it's almost kind of been like mindless
action like mindless violence you know
as opposed to like
the character like focusing on the
nature of the red hood there's been a
few stories here and there that have
kind of shifted that up a bit but like
being written like this it's just it's
amazing to see and jason todd
has enough right like like literally red
hood has enough and so you have barbara
gordon watching jason todd and she's
like okay
literally his hand's shaking and it's
like he's literally falling in line with
like the killing joke joker's philosophy
right like all it takes is one bad day
and it's like he's he's sitting there
shaking and barbara gordon's like oh my
god he's gonna do it and like jason todd
doesn't want to but like he doesn't he
pulls the trigger
barbara gordon throws a batarang and
misses and jason todd
shoots the joker through the head like
he kills the joker who killed him and
it's just like
holy cow and barbara gordon's like what
did you do
what did you do and jason's like i ended
it right like i finally
ended this like i finally killed the
joker and barbara gordon
storms out right because she's like he's
like dude you wanted this as much as i
did and she's like no i didn't want any
of this and he says let me ask you
something barbara gordon when was the
last time you missed when you threw your
batarang and it seems to be that like
she did kind of want that like she did
sort of want the joker to die like on
some
super personal level that she's not
willing to admit to herself she wanted
that version of the joker to die
and so like she's like screw you like
she ultimately ends up storming off and
jason taj is sort of staring over this
body he simply says like i hope that's
the right one
right like i really hope this is the
right joker
alright guys we are picking back up
again with the three jokers and again if
you guys haven't bought this
you really need to right like this is
one of these stories that you
really need to buy and just sit at home
and read right
we're coming up on the fall anyway so
those of you guys who live anywhere but
like the southwest
you guys know as one it's getting around
that time of year where it's just a
great time
to like buy some comic books and just
read right like you guys know what i'm
talking about uh but it's it's
ridiculously amazing and at the end of
this i actually have a question for you
guys hopefully i'll remember to ask it
what we end up doing here is we pick up
initially with the comedian who
basically arrives home now this is kind
of cool
because the idea behind the communion
the way this kind of played out here is
we had different iterations of the joker
right we had three versions of the joker
we had the criminal we had the clown and
we had the comedian the clown was the
one who
shot barbara gordon during the killing
joke right that's the way it seemed to
kind of point out or
seem to be the direction that they were
going in the comedian is the one that we
have here
and the uh and the the criminal is like
the classic joker
and the way this goes down is you
basically have this you know this this
comedian you know the comedian basically
uh showing up at his home by showing up
showing up there to meet his wife
and to meet his kid this is kind of the
weird thing here because it almost kind
of points to the idea
that this is the guy who shot barbara
gordon right like this comedian is the
one who shot barbara
that the the clown was not the one who
killed barbara gordon it seems to be
kind of like jeff john sort of throwing
that out there right kind of introducing
that idea to us but you get this
scenario where you basically have a
meeting with his wife and basically
talking to their kid now the reason why
i say that is because those of you guys
who remember the story the killing joke
this woman looks a lot like his wife
right she looks a lot like the wife of
the joker before he became the joker in
the killing joke and she was pregnant so
it's kind of one of these things of like
what happens if she didn't die
right what happened if she wasn't killed
by the criminals joker still became
joker but like she wasn't killed by the
criminals and he just kind of went on
living his life as the joker with like a
family and all that kind of stuff well
it's pretty screwed up to be honest with
you
right like the little kid's like why
can't we just leave and she's like you
know i'm you we can't
he'll come after us he'll find us that
kind of a thing she's like you need to
come down to dinner you got to play your
part right you got to play the role it's
the only way for us to basically survive
this whole ordeal and so what you end up
getting
is this really really strange kind of
dinner right it's not it's not wildly
crazy like you know the new 52 death of
the family right where like they're
eating with their faces cut off or at
least they believe their faces are cut
off
it's just like a very tense and
terrifying situation because nobody
knows what goes on in the joker's head
right like the joker could just
arbitrarily kill you and it wouldn't
make sense to anybody but himself but at
the end of the day that's all he really
cares about it makes sense to him and
that's all that really matters
the other part of this is that they're
having octopus for dinner and while the
kid doesn't really like octopus the
joker's like okay well let's see if we
can't turn that frown upside down right
what do you call
octopus triplets that look exactly alike
a tentacle
which is kind of weird but the joker
just cracks up laughing and if i'm being
honest with you guys i think it's funny
because of the joker right
like here's okay here's a question i
want to ask you guys in the old batman
the animated series cartoon show
where you had mark hamill voicing the
joker how many of you guys would laugh
when the joker laughed because you just
couldn't help it
that was me i just couldn't help it it
was just funny
it was hilarious listening to him laugh
but we basically end up snapping back to
reality
right and you've got the criminal who
basically asks you know comedian who
were like who were you talking to like
like what are you what are you doing
here he's like i was having dinner and
he asked with whom and he says with
myself
and that's this is kind of an
interesting thing because he's like well
you're basically wasting time
right like the problem that you have is
nobody else out there matters
except for batman right it was your idea
to let him in on our little secret right
to give him give him a trail to follow
to make it more fun and now one of us is
dead right you basically led the bat
family to one of us
you know to to the clown and you got him
killed and it's kind of nuts here
because looking at the first
looking at the first video that we did
the way this played out is
jeff johns kind of pointed at the idea
that the clown was the one who like
killed jason todd
and the comedian was the one who shot
barbara gordon that was kind of like the
way this worked right it was kind of him
basically saying like here are the
jokers that you know and it's kind of
wild
because with this going down you
basically pick up with jim gordon and
you you kind of have like this apartment
that belongs to a judge where the dogs
are all like joker infected right like
which
sounds horrifying right like they look
like rottweilers or
or like pitbulls they look like
rottweilers to be honest but like
they're infected by joker toxin right so
batman gets in there batman knocks them
out but
it's one of these things where you
basically end up finding out that this
guy was at least it was believed that he
was mauled to death by his own dogs and
in some ways he was but he was also
exposed to the joker toxin and it's one
of these things where
it's it's a question that's kind of
being asked here why is judge walls
the person here right like why is judge
walls a person who's dead this doesn't
really make any sense and the response
to batman
is well you know when when jim gordon
says like he retired years ago the
response to batman was he didn't retire
he was forced out right he was a dirty
judge he was taking bribes from from
like the old arkham officials to send
criminals to arkham asylum right so no
big loss that this judge is gone right
he was a bad judge he was a dirty judge
the world's probably better off without
him
but it's one of these things where where
at the end of the day
barbara gordon basically walks in and
where jim gordon's like i thought you
were escorting one of the jokers the
response to barbara is i need to talk to
batman and when he asks like where's the
red hood she says you know
it's it's like well you know
commissioner gordon's like you guys are
looking for the red hood too and
batman's like the red hood's not a
criminal and that's when barbara says
yes he is and there's kind of this
unwritten communication here that's like
i need to talk to you right now right so
you basically end up having the two of
them take off batman in the batmobile
barbara gordon on the on her little bat
cycle whatever it is and they kind of
have this thing where where juarez like
he killed
he killed the joker he killed one of
them like what are we gonna do about
this
and batman does not take the approach
that you think you would you think
batman would say okay then like let's
go grab jason todd like we're not gonna
kill him or anything but like we're
gonna take him like we're gonna take him
we're gonna take him to
you know to some place where he can't
escape from right we'll finish the rest
of this out and then we'll basically go
through and uh and then we'll deal with
jason todd and find out why he did what
he did right but like that joker's
already dead
there's not much to be done saving
gotham is more important and while
batman does take that approach to a
degree he actually tries to rationalize
the actions of jason todd you know and
saying you know that when barbara
gordon's like now we have to deal with
two more jokers and the red hood because
we don't know where he is we can't find
him he's out there in gotham somewhere
and he doesn't
like red hood cannot be found if he does
not want to be found right like he knows
us
he knows exactly what we would do and
how he would look for them and he knows
how to dodge us
but batman kind of responds and saying
like he killed a joker barber like
that's all we
know right all we know is that we killed
a joker and there you know that he
killed a joke and there's this kind of
back and forth right that where barbara
gordon is just kind of like no he shot a
human being tied to a chair like that's
a problem
the response of of batman is you know
the joker hurt him right like he healed
wrong
he got more violent you got stronger and
batman kind of tries to rationalize this
and basically saying like there's
something wrong with jason todd that's
why he did what he did almost kind of
making this argument it's not really
jason's fault that he did what he did
now he doesn't say it in so many words
but it kind of looks like that's more or
less an
argument that he's creating and batman
kind of looks at that and says like i've
never forgiven myself for leaving him in
that grave right because when jason todd
died in the original death of the
family's
death in the family storyline when he
died and that he was for all intents and
purposes dead right
i mean that's kind of how it was batman
put him in the ground batman buried him
the fact that jason todd was actually
alive
did not become a thing until you got to
like under the red hood
slash infinite crisis and the big
question that barbara gordon had is that
if batman believes he should talk to
jason todd and understand him then it
turns into why are you doing it now
right jason todd's been back all this
time why are you just now at a point
where you believe he needs to be talked
to you now here's the big issue that we
have with the three jokers right
we don't know when this story takes
place and that's really the big question
that a lot of you guys have i saw you
got a lot of you guys asking that in the
previous video
when does this story take place because
red hood has his own story arc going on
right now that has nothing to do with
this
when does this take place does it take
like do we is this a story that
basically takes place at the very
beginning of dc rebirth and if you want
to do a great big chronology you would
just put this at the very beginning of
the chronology right so
read it once you read dc universe
rebirth number one right i mean is that
is that what this is like we don't
really know where it fits in we don't
know if it takes place before doomsday
clock after doomsday clock we don't
really know we're not really given a
definitive answer here
because it was a story that looks like
it was supposed to be written years ago
but the the whole point behind this
is that you basically end up picking up
with red hood now i love the way
that jeff johns writes red hood and jeff
johns is one of the
few writers that can write jason todd
incredibly well right he's one of the
few writers that can do that he
basically writes them in in
kind of the classic red hood fashion and
people who were fans of jason todd right
whether they got on board before or
whether like they're super old school
right so they've been reading since like
the 70s or they got on board with like
under the red hood and they've been
following him ever since but i have to
imagine
you guys love the way red hood's
depicted here right because it's classic
jason tot
this guy like literally grabs one of the
joker's henchmen and just snatches him
up and it's like you guys were basically
told to find a place to hide a whole lot
of chemicals so you better have a good
response where did you hide them where
did you put them and this guy is just
kind of like i can't say like i'm not
going to tell you because if i do the
joker's going to do worse than me right
like like he would do worse
he would do worse than anything you
could do right he would kill me in the
worst possible way and the response of
jason is you don't have to tell me
detectors in the hood are already
picking it up right it's basically pool
cleaner now this is where you kind of
defect from classic red hood if this was
the under the red hood story if it was
like that version of the red hood
he would have killed this guy like that
he would have been like well now i'm
done with you pow and then like that
would have been the end of it right
instead he's like we're gonna hand you
over to the cops and this is kind of
cool because jeff
jones plays on this idea that jason todd
understands the severity of what it
meant to kill that joker and he's trying
not to fall down that slippery slope
right which is one of those important
things when people kind of make the
argument well if batman killed a guy
then batman would become as bad as a
criminal
only if he allowed himself to be you can
stop
the slippery slope argument is like
saying just because you sit down in a
casino table one time means you're never
gonna get up again and you're gonna turn
into a degenerate gambler that's not
true that's not true at all
basically saying people are not in
control of themselves right it's just
it's a really good way to absolve
yourself of responsibility right and so
with that being the case
it's one of these things where batman's
kind of like okay we'll try to find
jason todd but at the old you know at
the moment we can't we can't find him
right we tried tracking him we can't
locate him because he doesn't want to be
found and so he basically says we're
gonna go someplace else and they end up
going to black gate right now the reason
why they go to black gate is because of
the fact that batman says
that there were fingerprints that were
found on the body of judge walls and
when barbara asks who do these
fingerprints belong to
batman's response is joe chill right now
as soon as he gets into black gay prison
actually one of the inmates here is
rupert thorne which is awesome to see
rupert thorne is old school he's
super old school he was part of the old
steve engelhardt batman run and i think
that's where he was introduced although
i'm not gonna swear to it but of course
you end up picking up with like the
cell of joe chill when batman gets in
there he kind of chokes up for a second
right he's like you know who uh
you know who i am right he kind of gets
caught up in the moment right like it
really shows that batman
is still afraid of joe chill it's it's a
very small
and a very nuanced thing it can be kind
of easy to miss but that's exactly what
it is
batman is still afraid of joe chill and
it's like damn right like he still
really is just a little kid crying over
the fact that his mommy and his daddy
got shot but as soon as he gets into the
cell
joe chill's gone and that's when barbara
shows up and says like they moved him
right like he's basically sick and you
end up finding out that he's in the
hospital wing and he's got weeks to live
because he's dying of stage four cancer
and so the question becomes
if joe chill's dying of cancer how did
somebody get their hands on his
fingerprints and how did they get
get those fingerprints to the body of
judge walls right now
that can be done in any variety of ways
right the joker could just sneak in here
pretending to be like a doctor hide his
hair right put like a mask over his face
or something like that like like what
what's his name did
in the dark knight right what um what
heath ledger did pretend to be a nurse
it was the ugliest damn nurse i ever saw
in my life but pretend to be a nurse
right and then basically walk in there
and steal the guy's fingerprints right
just put some tape on his fingerprints
and then
put it on the crime scene somewhere it's
not hard to do nonetheless batman kind
of picks up on this and and where
barbara asked a question like what's
what's the connection right between the
joker
and joe chill and like everything else
besides you like what's the connection
there and so we end up finding out here
is that jason todd basically accessed
the bat computers from his helmet alfred
picked up on the location and basically
says hey like go find him over there
right so we end up basically picking up
and the gotham city athletic association
which is a condemned building so
obviously joker would operate out of it
and once red once red hood gets up there
he actually pulls a crowbar out which is
cool once he gets into this place where
this pool is it's literally
filled with bodies right like it is
littered
with bodies and he sticks a tooth or i'm
sorry a q-tip down
in there and it starts to hiss right so
it looks like it's a pool filled with
joker toxins they're using people as
experiments to
like use this toxin to achieve a goal
what that goal is we don't know like
presumably they're trying to recreate
the chemical that made joker into who he
was at ace chemical presumably that
formula has been lost
right over some measure of time or
they're just making more of it and so
initially like this body kind of flies
out and it's just sort of like oh my god
you know like this person's infected
joker kicks him back into the water
and that guy is basically dead now but
then he's taken from behind by one of
the jokers right he's
snatched up you know and they're kind of
like we'd hoped you'd come and you get
this
amazing like probably the single best
moment in this whole story jason todd
basically wakes up tied to a chair right
and you have the criminal
who's there he's like you know jason
todd petty thief you should have been
cuffed and arrested but then batman took
you in
to make you the second robin you were
reborn and then after your death
you were reborn again right that's
that's the origin of jason todd
summed up in seven panels but he says
like things always happen in threes
you had a life you were killed you came
back to life and now you're gonna be
reborn again right you've been reborn
twice
time to be reborn a third time and it's
one of these things where he responds
and he's like i killed one of those
jokers i'm gonna kill you too
and this version of the joker just
starts laughing almost maniacally and
then he responds right it looks like
it's a painful experience he responds to
jason and he says i'll let you in on a
secret about the joker it hurts when i
laugh here's here's
here's the thing all right i'm gonna be
honest with you guys here's the thing i
like the criminal i
like this version of the joker the way
that jeff johns write him dc comics
never use him again right like never
ever ever ever ever ever
ever bring him back or use him again
right like just
let him stay like this keep him like
this let this be the last time we ever
see him because if you do some other
writer is going to get their hands on
him and they're going to screw it up
do not do anything with the criminal
joker right so it's one of these things
where jason's kinda like so you're
telling me you're the real joker and
that's when he chimes in and he says who
is the joker really and so it really
seems to point at this idea that the
joker is not necessarily a person
the joker's an ideology and that's
something that really dc's been pointing
at for a number of years through various
stories right like scott snyder's new 52
run
steve ingleheart you can even go all the
way back or you can go all the way back
during
the era of like dennis o'neil and neil
adams right they're like the joker's a
concept he's an ideology the joker
represents chaos and anybody can be the
joker if there's somebody who believes
that chaos
needs to be supreme but for all intents
and purposes we as readers identify with
the joker as being a particular person
right like as being an
individual who's running around doing
things but that's what makes this
interesting is because what happens if
you have three individuals out there who
all believe that batman is bad and like
chaos should reign supreme all they have
to do is make themselves look like a
joker and then they are
right like that's really all it takes
and so they asked jason the question
they say
why put on that helmet and call yourself
red hood after what we did to you right
because red hood was the was the persona
of the joker before he became the joker
right in almost every single iteration
of his character he's been red hood
before he was the joker and of course
you know having
having beat him to death the response of
jason todd is it's a joke right it's a
play on you
you killed me so i'm going to become not
necessarily you directly but i'm going
to become a mockery of what you stand
for and i'm going
you know my goal is to to basically
fight alongside batman right to use this
thing
that you consider to be so important
this this representation of chaos
and become that but become the opposite
of that to stand in line with batman
against you and so it's one of these
things where they're like is it really a
joke because like we left you with brain
damage and permanent nerve pain
physical and emotional trauma so severe
that the only relief
you ever find is when you inflict pain
on others you and me boy
were more alike than you'd care to admit
and that is
true that's 100 true the joker finds
satisfaction with hurting people that's
the nature of the joker he finds
enjoyment
in that now usually it's part of some
greater scheme but he finds satisfaction
and inflicting harm on others
specifically if the harm that he can
inflict can affect batman and get batman
to chase after him again the joker finds
enjoyment out of that
and so the criminal kind of looks at
jason and says like you know that
already right you nearly died and you
blame the batman
for it you hate him for it and he says i
do too now this seems to point at the
origin the joker seemingly this idea
that all the origins of the joker are
the same in the sense that he
encountered batman
under some strange circumstance whether
it's because he was in the wrong place
at the wrong time what have you but he
was knocked into a bat of chemicals and
that led to him becoming who he was but
he almost died in that bat of chemicals
that's the joker's stance right so
that's why red hood and the joker are so
similar it's one of these things where
the joker kind of says you hate him most
of all
right like you hate the batman most of
all because he's the reason why you are
where you are and he says batman
needs a better joker but simply put
you're not bright enough
you the way you are are not good enough
and so he says tell me jason
does it hurt when you laugh and then you
basically end up having him cracked over
the head with a crowbar again now this
is where things get kind of murky here
because the comedian
starts cracking jason todd over the head
and then starts saying you know
this really is more fun than it was the
first time right so it looks like this
is the version of the joker that killed
jason todd jeff johns
seems like he could be going back and
forth now it could also be that i'm
remembering it wrong right but it seems
like he's kind of going back and forth
in between issue number one and issue
number two which really kind of begs the
question
what if these are just three different
versions of the same guy right like
three different personas or something
like that they're of seemingly the same
individual right so like there's
one joker there's the criminal element
to the joker there's the the clown
element to the joker and the comedian
element to the joker right so the
serious nature the goofy nature and the
one who just does things for the fun of
it and then what if something happened
and it just
manifested into three different versions
we're not really giving an answer here
right we're just kind of guessing at
this point in time but we're back where
we're
seemingly jason todd's being cracked
over the head he basically says you
better make sure i stay dead this time
because if i don't i'm gonna come back
and i'm gonna kill you and the joker's
like no what are you talking about i'm
rooting for you i'm hoping you rise back
up and you prove us wrong
i'm hoping you become the joker right
cue to barbara gordon busting the door
in alongside batman right and once they
get in there they're immediately
surrounded by like all these joker guys
right these these joker looking guys you
know and initially like you know it's
kind of like they're they're not really
jokers they're just kind of people who
were taken in who were basically you
know
who were victims more or less but the
problem is that as they're attacking
batman
one of them hits his utility belt and
when that happens it basically ends up
calling in the batmobile which just
comes
flying into that location and actually
kills a bunch of these guys and so
batman's like you know like we can still
save some of them you know we can still
save jason
and it's kind of like save me like like
what are you talking about like i'm not
jason and that's one of these things
where it looked like it was jason todd
who was uh who was turned but apparently
it wasn't right he's like i'm not i'm
not you know but like i'm not jason
right like you know kind of barbara
gordon freaking out like jason is that
you and he's like no that's not jason
and so jason todd is not there right the
pool's been drained jason todd's not
there and
ultimately they of course end up
locating it now once they bring him in
jason todd has not really turned he's
not really the joker right he just
starts freaking out going off on batman
you know batman's like are you alright
he's like am i okay like what do you
think right like you did this to me this
is the second time i've been snatched up
by the joker and been beat to death
at least this time you made it in time
right like you made it before i died but
you put me on this path
i'm in this life because of you if it
wasn't for you i wouldn't be here right
like i wouldn't be
in this moment in this time living this
life that i'm living right now like he
just wholly blames batman it's resent at
his at his absolute
worst you know i hate you for this i
hate you for the fact that you just
buried me into the ground and then just
replaced me with robin's willy-nilly
without giving it a thought right
without even caring at all and so
barbara gordon steps up and barbara
gordon is like okay calm down
we just need to get you someplace safe
now of course they end up taking her to
taking him to barbara's apartment and
then she starts screaming at batman
because batman's like i've gotta go do
stuff like check out gotham city because
i'm emotionally stunted i'm super stoic
which is not a practical lifestyle to
live
and uh and i just don't really reveal my
emotions to anybody because you know
reason and logic because that makes
perfect sense and so ultimately jason
todd of course wakes up realizing he's
in the the apartment of barbara gordon
he takes her book chronic pain
management right so we can kind of learn
how to how to cope with this whether his
chronic nerve pain that he experiences
and then once barbara gordon arrives
they kind of start having this
heart-to-heart conversation
and the response of barbara is there's
something that you have to understand
jason
we all really thought you were dead
everyone thought you were dead nobody
knew that you were alive
if anybody had known you were alive we
would have come and found you we would
have moved heaven and earth we would
have burned down whatever chant whatever
town we had to get to
that man would have taken out whoever he
had to get to in order to find you if we
had known that you were alive
we would have been there by your side
grabbing you and bringing
you back to a place that's safe but it's
one of these things where he just hadn't
quite really picked up on that you know
it's one of these things where she's
like you know we
we care about you we all wish we had
been there for you and he kind of
responds and saying that no one has ever
said that to him and she says she's
saying it now
and the two of them actually share a
kiss now whether or not this will turn
into something i don't really know and
i'm a little
a little weird about seeing like jason
todd and barbara gordon kissing it's a
little strange to me because they're not
really brother and sister but they're
kind of like adopted
kids to a degree like adopted brothers
and sisters so like a surrogate brother
or a surrogate sister
sister and brother is involved in their
relationship in some way and that's
bad to like that's weird to me to see
them like kissing
it's like ugh it's kind of gross but you
know barbara gordon immediately kind of
puts it away so there's only a moment
no like that's that's not going to
happen you know friend zone like this
it's not going to happen right it's just
that's just not going to take place and
so you basically end up getting this
this kind of thing where batman
basically goes back right and he's
looking at like all this information
that he has at his disposal right
missing clowns
missing criminals different things like
that basically the joker files you know
and kind of skimming through this stuff
and looking at this as best he can then
suddenly something has something to do
with alaska right like he picks him on
something that has something to do with
this place right with this state that's
out there somewhere and so you basically
end up switching over to joe chill who's
been taken
by the comedian right taken by the
comedian version of the joker he's
basically snatched up and a video
camera's put on him and he says okay
like
lights camera action time to talk and he
says it's finally time to confess mr
chill
why did you really kill thomas and
martha wayne because apparently the
reason that we got was not the reason
that it happened
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with the three
jokers yes this is the conclusion to the
three joker's storyline right keep in
mind that one of the jokers is dead
the clown joker is the one that was
killed by by jason todd the criminal
and the comedian are still alive but in
this video we are going to find out
which one of these jokers
is the real joker and it's amazing it's
such a great review
so initially this kind of picks up with
like batman and jason todd and barbara
gordon kind of conversing right about
all the information that they've seen
right you know the information that was
kind of brought together and the fact
that the joker wanted them to find all
this stuff right the three jokers one of
these guys one of these these three to
find
all these things that are here and so
one of the things that that was kind of
established in the last video
is that the jokers are created two of
these jokers were artificially created
in the sense that we have one main joker
and then he created the other two and so
the idea is that
if that's true then the question is
which joker is the real one right and
that's really what they're what they're
trying to figure out and then one of the
things that jason todd says is whichever
joker is the real joker once i find them
like once i set my sights on him
there'll be no jokers i'm gonna kill him
because you're too weak to do it batman
and when that happens bruce wayne freaks
out right like he immediately loses it
and starts going after jason todd and
the reason why and this this is what's
so cool i'm gonna be honest with you
guys this is what's so cool
i think this is the best that jason
todd's been written in years and i'm
just gonna say it but one of the things
that
that
man gets pissed out about a piss piss
off about is like do you really think
that i haven't wanted to put a put a
bullet
in the brain of the joker right do you
think i really didn't want to kill him
after everything that he did after
what he did to you after what he did to
barbara do you really think
i didn't want to and the response of
jason todd is but you didn't
of all the talk that you have you didn't
do it you wanted to you could have but
you didn't and that's one of the things
that's interesting right like whenever i
make this point about how batman should
kill his villains people usually kind of
default to the slippery slope argument i
never really consider that a a good
argument it's a fallacy because one it
assumes that you can't control yourself
right it assumes that you can't say like
i'm just going to stop here the problem
with the slippery slope argument is that
if you apply it to across the board and
you say okay let's apply this slippery
slope argument to anything then we can
say okay you should never have a single
drink of alcohol in your life because if
you do it's a slippery slope and you'll
become an alcoholic you should never
smoke weed once in your life because if
you do it's a slippery slope and you'll
become a drug addict right that's the
problem with the slippery slope argument
right it assumes
that batman couldn't sit down and reason
and say okay of all the villains that i
have
joker is by and far the worst because he
just kills people indiscriminately for
reasons that don't make sense to anybody
but himself but has something to do with
the fact that he wants me to come and
find him and for every time i capture
the joker he'll kill a hundred people
before i get him so we should just kill
him
and be done with it it assumes batman
can't define that reason right batman
can't say okay killing the joker that's
basically where it stops right i can't
justify killing
the penguin or anybody like that because
they're just they're they're criminals
right they do some pretty shady stuff
but nobody's as bad as the joker is for
the world's greatest detective i have a
hard time
believing he'd be unable to stop at that
line of logic so that
that's why i never really paid any
attention to the slippery slope argument
and just kind of ignored it because it's
the argument you make when you can't
make any other argument but
the crazy thing about this is that
batman basically says like you don't
understand right barbara gordon tries to
step in and kind of mediate things a
little bit but at the end of the day
they're both ignoring her
it's jason todd and batman and at the
end of the day batman's like you don't
understand
you you never have understood batman
doesn't say it in so many words but
jason todd
does not understand the effect it had on
bruce wayne and the reason why is
because they're children to bruce wayne
they're his kids
that's just that's that's that's just
the plain and simple statement of the
fact right sure barbara gordon has her
dad right she's got commissioner gordon
but batman sees them as children
especially jason todd tim drake and dick
grayson they're his kids
like he he took them on his wards by all
standards of measurement he was their
father or father figure and he was there
to make sure that no harm befell them he
knew the risk that he was taking here
but he also understood that they needed
to have an
outlet for their anger and their
vengeance and their desire to destroy
they needed a good way to channel it and
the best way to channel it is to one
allow them to help him on his missions
but two to curb that desire for revenge
into a desire to make people's lives
better and so along the way jason todd
kind of seemed to have gotten lost but
jason todd was beaten to death and when
jason todd came back and he was so angry
at batman because batman didn't kill the
joker that man wanted to but he didn't
because in his mind it wasn't the right
thing to do and so the results of this
is that you kind of have this little bit
of a of a breakdown right the batman
runs over the criminal joker and says
he's very reminiscent of the joker from
the early days like the old bob kane
bill finger joker right like the guy who
was just really sadistic really dark the
clown of course they faced at the
aquarium and jason todd killed him the
comedian
is the one where you see him laugh but
there's just something
there right there's just kind of like
this darkness this dark sadistic streak
behind the laugh and the smile
and the eyes that just shows this guy is
the worst of them all he's the absolute
worst of the jokers the most
violent of all the jokers and so because
of that it's okay
one of these three is the original joker
maybe we already killed him in the
aquarium maybe it's the criminal
mastermind maybe it's the comedian right
maybe it's the most sadistic of them all
but whichever one it is
one of them is the real joker and so the
question of barbara gordon is maybe we
finally find out like maybe we find out
the true origin of the joker and
at the end of the day like jason todd's
like maybe just some kind of a nobody
right
but where the questions asked like
batman do you know who the joker is
right like do you know his name the
response of bruce is no if i did know i
would have told you already
and so what you end up doing is picking
up in the aftermath of joe chill being
kidnapped right we saw that in the in
the last video that we did the last
comment that we did that joe chill was
kidnapped from blackgate prison while he
was basically going through medical
treatment and batman immediately wants
to see a cell now here's a crazy thing
is batman's going through
these these kind of books that were in
the cell of joe chill he came across
letters that joe chill wrote and none of
the letters were ever mailed out but
they were all made out to bruce wayne
and so where he
he basically ends up going to see
reverend evans right the guy who
essentially wins the show kind of you
know this this priest
you know who helps them find repentance
he's not the warden but the person that
helps them basically helps prisoners
kind of discover who they really are or
allows them to repent or whatever the
case is that when batman's talking to
him he basically says you know he says
no like these letters were never mailed
because they were never finished you
know he dropped out of school when he
was 13. he was doing his best in his
classes here but his learning disability
slowed him down right his inability to
read at an effective rate you know at an
effective level and that these letters
that he wrote were long before he became
ill
because the thought of batman and he
kind of want baron wants to deviate to
the idea that joe chill is still just a
bad person
it comforts him and that's why batman
says okay so the whole reason he wrote
these letters is because he got sick and
he just wanted to he wanted to repent
right like he wanted to make sure he
didn't go to hell when he died and the
response of reverend evans is no
he wrote those long before he fell ill a
long time before he fell ill now the
other part of this is you pick up with
barbara gordon and you pick up with with
dick grayson while batman's you know
inside talking to the reverend
and dick grayson initially kind of hits
up barbara gordon and says look uh you
know i know i kind of screwed up here
right like
i've put you guys in a rough position
but at the end of the day he also tells
her like we won't ever have anything
like that again and it's kind of an
important thing here because it gives us
a little bit of a softer side
of of jason todd and so it's a little
bit nuts there because
the question that reverend has is what
do they want with him right like why
take joe chill in the first place right
he's a dying man like he literally has
cancer his days are numbered and he
basically says like i'm going to find
out because what he finds among all
these letters is one that was obviously
written by the joker and it basically
has a ticket to the mark of zorro and so
again that's at the
the the monarch theater that was the
show that batman and his parents or
bruce wayne and his parents were going
to see when they died or had seen
when they died and so of course barbara
gordon and bruce wayne and
jason todd show up here and this begins
what's probably the single
greatest point in this whole story the
single greatest moment in this entire
story that when you have him show up
a movie begins to play and this movie is
is basically like the comedian joker
talking to joe chill and saying okay
kind of picking out where we left off in
the last one
why did you really kill thomas and
martha wayne i've read all your letters
i've read the minister's notes you've
seen the light right your your
experiences and the suffering that you
cause
have touched your soul they've touched
your immortal soul and you have looked
to repent
all of your sins but answer something
for me why did you
kill thomas and martha wayne really what
was the motivation behind it now batman
of course
ends up kind of making his way through
the theater as this movie's playing and
then finally comes across joe chill
who's currently being held by the
criminal and this is cool
because the criminal is not being
written as like a crazy goofy guy right
that was one of the cool things about
his character is he's methodical he
thinks he focuses that he that it hurts
him to laugh which i think is probably
one of the greatest additions to the
joker mythos
ever but what he says here is their
initial intention was to turn
jason todd into the new joker but the
problem with that is that jason todd
lacked sophistication and then they were
going to take barbara gordon but she's
got too much heart right so
he picked the killer uh he picked joe
chill the intention is to turn joe chill
into a new joker and it's one of the
things that's kind of nuts here is
because while this little bit of a
segment's happening
between criminal joker and between you
know batman that you've also got like
the comedian joker doing that interview
with joe chill they recorded and they're
putting on the movie screen and joe
chill you know to kind of nip this in
the bud real quick so we can kind of
focus on the meat and potatoes of this
joe chill the reason why he killed
thomas and martha wayne is because he
was struggling he was down on his luck
and he saw them and he believed that
people who were that rich
are the reason why he was that poor it
was their fault and so he wanted to take
some of what they had in order to
get himself back on his feet again right
and the result of that was that once he
got there and once he
essentially went to go rob them he
suddenly realized that bruce wayne's
there and before he knew it
the gun was going off right the gun was
going off and the result was that they
were basically killed but it wasn't
until
after everything that was going on that
he realized that thomas and martha wayne
which he already knew who they were but
they were actually people who were using
their money to make gotham city better
that they were looking to work against
those individuals who used their wealth
to buy politicians to make laws in their
favor things like that they were the
good guys and he killed two people who
were actually looking to make gotham
better who could have made his life
better but in his anger and in his
selfishness
he kind of categorized them all the same
everybody out there who's rich
is the reason why i'm poor right and and
there really isn't a direct corollary
between those two things it's not
necessarily because somebody's rich you
are poor
right it's not necessarily that way but
joe chill saw it that way and that's
what led him to committing the act that
he did now that admission will become
much more important later on down the
line but batman
initially approaches joe chill with the
intention of freeing him and criminal
joker reveals he's got his whole chest
strapped with dynamite now
that's a classic move for the criminal
joker if you go back and you read the
old
the old bob kane bill finger stories
right do you ever get your chance you
know you can you can buy them on i think
you can buy them directly from dc
or you can grab them on comicsology you
can go read those super old batman
stories right batman number one number
two number three go read those really
old stories with the joker and that's
the kind of stuff you would do and so
you end up having you know
barbara gordon and jason todd facing off
against like these kind of jokerized
people right these jokerized individuals
who are out there but as barbara
gordon's facing off against a couple of
them they both get shot and when she
initially believes it's jason todd she
turns around and is the comedian joker
the one who shot her
right the one who shot her from killing
jokes still wielding that same camera
that he had his outfit's different but
he's still got the same camera and he's
like time for you to smile and so it's
like a great tribute to the killing joke
right it's like an amazing tribute to
the killing joke and so the the
motivation behind creating a new joker
and even the motivation behind the
creation of these jokers is revealed
when the criminal tells batman he wants
to be more
he needs to be everything to batman the
biggest issue that he has with batman
is he's not his main focus now that's a
that's a common point that joker's had
over the years it's not something jeff
jones is making up on the spot that's
been the motivation behind joker for
years for eons and eons and eons that he
wants to be the one the batman focuses
on he wants to be the center of batman's
life he almost in kind of a sadistic and
screwed up way
sees batman is like a lover it's a
dissatisfaction right the fact that he
doesn't have batman focusing on him in
that way
leaves him dissatisfied and so initially
batman's response is joe chill's a sick
dying old man of what use would he be to
you and that's when criminal joker says
i'm willing to bet that this little bath
will put him into remission i'm willing
to bet if we dunk him in this water that
is going to cure his cancer it'll make
him insane but it'll cure his cancer and
he will be
one of us and that's kind of the crazy
thing here right that's kind of the
crazy situation
because right now this criminal joker
defines the concept of the joker as
undefined chaos we're just absolute
chaos there's no rhyme and reason to
us being like you don't see us as like a
form and a function right you don't see
us as we truly are that we are the
antithesis to you
instead you see us as just like crazy
guys who implement some schemes and do
some things and all hell pops off for a
little while and then things go back to
normal right like you capture us and
then we go to jail and that's basically
it but i need to be more
we as a joker need to be more and so at
that point like literally joker pulls
out a tommy gun
goes to shoe batman of course batman
dodges out of the way but in the process
the ropes start to snap the joker falls
the lighter falls out of his hand and
ends up
ends up landing in this vat of chemicals
which of course turns us this great
huge chemical thing on fire and so in
that moment when when criminal joker
goes to fight bruce wayne you've also
got
uh the comedian joker facing off against
barbara gordon and it's just kind of
like i've never i haven't had this much
fun in a long long time and we're just
getting started and when part of the
roof begins to collapse and it doesn't
quite kill barbara gordon then but when
part of the roof
starts to collapse the comedian ends up
bailing out right he ends up taking off
and so you've got the the criminal joker
facing off against batman he goes to cut
the wire so that uh joe chill will fall
inside the burning chemical bath right
like the water has to be on fire in
order for it to fully effect right in
order for it to fully take effect but he
cuts them loose and then batman saves
joe chill and that's a crazy thing
is the criminal was not relying on
batman saving joe chill that he was
kind of relying on batman's hatred of
joe chill to just let him die
right now i wouldn't necessarily say
that batman saves joe chill because he's
like you know i don't kill i don't let
anybody not you know i think it's really
more of
batman saves joe chill because he
doesn't want to deal with another joker
i think that's really what kind of goes
on here but of course he ends up
swinging back into action going after
the criminal again and then once once
the criminals temporarily knocked out
joe chill kind of looks at batman as
like i know who you are they talk about
you in blackgate
and you know what i did in this place
are you going to kill me and it's it's a
little bit ambiguous here
right it's a little bit ambiguous here
it's one of these things where joe chill
almost kind of wants batman to kill him
i mean well i guess it's not really
ambiguous he says i deserve
it but it's almost kind of like he wants
batman to kill him but the cool thing
about this is joe chill
is exceedingly remorseful for his
actions
and that's an important thing because
batman's initial response is like
no i'm not going to kill you and that's
when joe shows like i deserve it i'm
truly sorry for what i did
this combined with with batman's
knowledge of the fact that joe chill had
written these letters before he became
sick indicates that he really is
remorseful he's not remorseful because
he's on his last days
he really does feel terrible about what
he did because joe chill one
turned the life of bruce wayne upside
down and two doomed gotham he made
gotham what it is by getting rid of
thomas and martha wayne and allowing
corruption among the police and among
politicians and among the ultra wealthy
to run supreme he made gotham the way
that it is he single-handedly screwed up
the whole town and so it's kind of crazy
because of course the bricks start to
fall and then batman rescues him again
and you know he says thank you batman's
like you're welcome but in that moment
the criminal pops back up again right
and he says like i hope to extend this
game more but now
we all go together right and gets ready
to pull this this stick of dynamite and
he's shot by the comedian right the
comedian shoots him in the head and says
and then there was
one take me away bats arrest me and take
me away now
the big question here is why even kill
him why even kill him in the first place
why kill the criminal well the reason
for this comes after barbara gordon and
jason todd share a moment where
jason todd's kind of pissed about batman
just kind of sitting him back to the bad
cape but he also asked barbara gordon is
there really a chance about us right
because
remember like they shared a kiss and
barbara's like no you know he gets
friend zoned basically he's like you'd
make a really good friend you know i
don't know what to tell you i don't feel
that way about you right he just
basically gets shut down and so of
course you know the two of them end up
going their separate ways temporarily
but batman starts having a conversation
with the joker and the joker says like
he's literally
see now after all of that drama don't
you feel better bruce right bruce wayne
robert gordon jason todd
you know i know but i don't care i'm not
gonna tell anybody right the world can
never know your true name
you might stop doing this if i do right
if i tell people
who you really are right you might quit
and that really kind of solidifies
a lot of what was established in scott
snyder's new 52 batman run that the
joker doesn't care about bruce wayne's
identity as batman that what he cares
about is the cat and mouse game that
they chase each other around
they just go round and round and round
in circles the funny thing about this
is when batman asks the question what is
it that you want right the joker says
what do i want
certainly not what the others did the
clown your troubled robin
put a bullet in all he wanted to do was
laugh at the suffering of others
how common right and the criminal that
old man
was so delusional this whole great big
idea of creating
a better joker well that's just lunacy
right a defined joker
one with a name and identity that ruins
the very definition of me
that's why i regret making him or he
says
does he regret making me the reality of
this if i'm really a betting man here
this is the original joker the comedian
is the original joker and this comes in
a couple different ways like when batman
says what's the punch line the joker
says that's the point there's no final
twist right not until i decide to put my
knife into your heart but he says the
criminal was absolutely wrong
i am chaos right i'm the devil i'm
nothing and everything to you the joker
is not the one who's broken
it's batman who's broken all of this was
basically my plan
batman was broken by a greater pain than
any of us
could ever inflict on you and so i
convinced them that making joe chill the
new joker would be the best
idea right the man who destroyed gotham
the man who destroyed you
making him into the joker into like
another joker would crush you right it
would destroy you
on some level in a way that i never
really could and the irony behind all
this
is he says like you save the man who
kills your parents who sent the city
literally spiraling down into your end
of despair this man apologized to you
which is exactly what you needed to hear
and so because of me
your greatest wound has been healed and
so now i
can be your greatest pain i will cut you
i'll hurt you
oh i'll destroy your life in every
conceivable way that i possibly can
because now i am your only real focus
you're dealt with joe chill you dealt
with that that pain and that struggle
and that anger that you've been carrying
around all your life that wound
is now healed now there's the wounds
that i can create i can become
your source i can become your source of
anger and your source of pain
i can become the thing that you hate the
most in this world i am now your main
focus
that was the whole plan behind this
right that was the whole basis behind
this it's an amazing reveal but bruce
wayne of course
goes to visit joe chill and and
basically accepts joe chill's apology
right the two of them actually end up
holding hands which is
a massive moment and he actually holds
the hand of joe chill
as he dies and so while batman didn't
necessarily tell joe chill in that
alleyway i forgive you
this is bruce wayne appearing to joe
chill as joe chill
needed for bruce wayne to appear to him
and say i forgive you for what you've
done
forgiveness is what bruce wayne needed
to heal himself and it's what joe chill
needed to finally be able to come to
terms with what it was that he did
george hill
of course dies and he ends up being
buried and then batman or bruce wayne
ends up traveling to alaska and he
basically says he kind of has this
little bit of a statement the world can
never know your true name you end up
having this bit of a conversation that
batman has with alfred now there is also
a letter that that
red hood leaves for barbara gordon and
says that like i want to make a change
right but i can't do that without you
basically like it's a confession of love
it's a confession of love that he needs
barbara gordon the problem is like the
letter falls off the wall and ends up
being swept away by just some random guy
so she never gets the letter and jason
todd says i'll never bring it up if you
never say anything to me then i'll
assume you tore the letter up and threw
it away and i'll never ask you about it
if you never come to me and talk about
it i'll never come to you and i'll
assume that if you never came to me and
talked to me about it that you didn't
want to be a part of my life in that way
that you didn't want to love me in that
way that you didn't want us
to become something it's actually tragic
right it's insanely
tragic right because if i'm being honest
as weird as it is that barbara gordon
and jason todd kiss because they're kind
of like adopted brother and sister i
guess i could kind of ship them
you know see them going together i don't
really know but batman ends up having a
conversation with alfred
and the crazy thing about this is you
basically have bruce wayne talking to
alfred and saying i don't mean to sound
the way that people think i do but like
i'm batman right i knew the joker's name
one week after we first met i've known
his identity the entire time and then
you get these little moments these
little scenes that come from the killing
joke and basically like you end up
having the wife of the joker where in
the killing joke the jo the explanation
to the joker's wife was that he died the
reality of this
is that it looks as though that's not
true that she was actually
sent away because it looked like she
would never ever ever be free of the
joker
how the the nature of these two guys
consolidates with the way they were
depicted right because they referred uh
to the jokers like sir
different things like that doesn't quite
make a whole lot of sense you know but
but anyway she's basically talking to
cops and you end up having you know
having her basically escorted away
essentially it looked like her death was
fate but she ends up getting away from
from you know the joker before he became
the joker and she ends up traveling to
alaska where she's been this entire time
with her kid that she's raising and so
what this points to
and what and then what i'm going with
this is the real joker out of all three
of these guys the real joker
is the killing joke joker the criminal
joker and the the the clown joker they
were created
by the comedian right they were created
by him and that they're not actually
jokers they were just two random guys
out there who for whatever reason the
comedian joker chose so the comedian
is the true joker right the origin of
the killing joke is the actual origin
of the joker right and it makes sense
that's the one that fans go with the
most but that's where things stand right
now
killing joe joker that story is the
original origin of the joker he is the
original joker right so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
here
[Music]
so
[Music]